nobody knows anything about Al's going
on with my lights out here they don't my
own lines are out here and that's all
people know
they are so mysterious people don't see
them they're like little cat yetis okay
take away that cat Yeti thing brilliant
cat safety is our our most important
priority as the cat walks through here
it's gonna stuff here here here and it's
too far I reach to go over there so he's
just gonna go right here and get caught
in the snare
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
we've captured 25 adult and sub-adult
mountain lions over the last 10 years
we've put GPS collars on and then we've
also caught four kittens
yeah he's plenty big when a mount line
is born it'll stay with his mother and
nurse for two months and then stay with
its mother for another year or so
learning to hunt and then after about a
year and a half to two years old the
mother will leave them then you have a
sub-adult lion that has to find its own
territory the dispersing sub-adults that
we've had they've gone very long
distances we had one travel from the
Davis Mountains almost to Big Bend
National Park the data from our colored
adult mountain lions had an average of
about 150 square miles for their home
range but we head up to 400 square miles
home range going in on a kill with a cat
president I mean it's a little
nerve-racking you can't help us just be
able to feel the eyes on you so yeah
when you're going in on this fresh kill
sides knowing that it's still there that
it stealthily took down this full-grown
deer and it's watching you just the same
yeah my folks I think you're more
freaked out than I am about anything but
as they should be as parents should be
using these colors can find out what
they're eating and what they're doing
out here
[Music]
mountain lions are unregulated in terms
of their harvest in Texas they could be
trapped they can be shot
there aren't any limits on the number
that you can chill or your methods of
tape with a sample size of 21 cats
survival was about a 53 percent annual
survival for the cats that we had
collared the biggest mystery to me is
how this population continues to persist
in the Davis Mountains what is it what's
that mechanism that's keeping these
animals still here this populations
still around is an immigration from you
know the south from Mexico Big Bend
National Park is an immigration from the
north is it isolated populations of high
surviving females Matlin's symbolize
mystery they're mysterious they are
lucid they're secretive but they're
amazing animals
this population in West Texas has
remained here for centuries
[Music]
understanding of how it's still here
making sure it continues to [ __ ] to
still be here that's an important thing
[Music]
you
you
[Music]